>>Female presenter: Welcome, everyone and
welcome to Google. We're happy to have you
here with us for the Speaker Series for our
second exhibit. This is part of the Digital
Arts Exhibit that we're holding at Google
in collaboration with The Project Room at
the Chelsea Art Museum. So, initially, the
idea behind the exhibition was an idea by
Josh Schmitterlin, a colleague of ours, who
thought that Google should be more involved
in the local art scene; especially in the
local digital arts scene and maybe that the
effort would eventually lead to a collaboration
between digital artists and Google. So, this
is our second exhibit and we're very happy
to be holding the Speaker Series with two
great speakers today. Our first speaker today
was gonna be Rachel Armstrong and I'll have
to read this because it's a long list. Too
many qualifications. She's a medical doctor,
a multimedia producer, a science fiction author,
an arts collaborator, so we have an exceptional
person here. And her current research is on
architectural design and mythologies about
new technology. And you've probably heard
about living architecture, so she's gonna
be giving us a talk and you guys can ask her
some questions towards the end and after our
talks end, you could also look at the exhibit
outside.
>>Rachel: Thank you very much. All right,
so it's been a great pleasure for me to be
here in New York today. Particularly as I
had to walk 40 blocks in the rain--
[laughter]
and realized after about block ten, that New
York drain engineers don't appear to know
how to build drains. Secondly, that made me
realize, also, that architecture really is
about dryness and that no matter what city
that you're in, rain is always a surprise.
Which leads me, actually, to the materials
that I'm working with cause actually, they
are designed to work with wetness. And I don't
know if anybody has managed to go around the
exhibition just now. I haven't had a chance
to look so I can't tell you exactly where
it is, but my contribution here are some black
and white films, which I did with Michael
Simon Toon. And essentially, they are synthetic
agents made from simple oil and water, but
have life-like properties. And so, the talk
I'm gonna do now really relates to why I'm
interested in life as a technology and how
that is applied in a design and specifically
architectural context. The examples I'm going
to use is a work that I've been doing around
the city events, which, as you know, is rather
an interesting and tempestuous relationship
with water. So essentially, I'm designing
living materials for the built environment.
I'm gonna start with a quote, written in 1771,
that starts, "According to Mr. Blainville,
who usually is trustworthy, one can predict
that in less than a hundred years will Venice
be totally united with the rest of Italy and
you can walk dry-shod from Italy to the city."
What we're really bad at is predicting the
future and what we're really good at is somehow,
surviving it. According to scientists, life
was extinguished many times on early Earth,
before it finally established itself 4.5 billion
years ago. The Earth's environment is not
kind and for any structure on its surface
to persist requires a huge amount of energy.
In nature, even mountains are moved. So, what
makes life so resilient? Well, the answer
is we don't exactly know, but it's embodied,
it's robust, it's flexible and it's able to
change with environmental fluctuations so
that it keeps its contingency at every moment
because when it doesn't, it no longer possesses
that special quality of life. Life has this
ability to persist, which is unlike any other
persistent structure on the Earth's surface.
For example, the City of Venice, and I know
I'm personifying madly here, but this is to
get my point across. For Venice to persist
against the forces of nature, the environment,
the change in climate, it's standing there
in opposition to all this and it's had to
ally itself with the contemporary technologies
of the time, not because of its living properties.
So, Venice, when it was first established
as a city-state between the 12th, I'm sorry,
the 9th and the 12th century, was dependant
on agrarian technologies. Essentially, this
meant land drainage because of the resources
of the sea. And with the settlement and it
needed the construction of canals for transport
and the use of woodpiles to shore up the foundations
of the developing settlement. And these, of
course, form a large part of the city even
today. Now, with the advent of industrial
technologies, great wealth and power came
to Venice. And it came with a price. In order
for the Industrial Revolution to create opportunities
for growth and proliferation and wealth creation
for the population of Venice, and also the
surrounding countries with which Venice was
trading, required top down intensive energy
expensive processes that gave atomic precision
control over matter. And that had huge environmental
cost; one that Venice is still paying today.
This is an industrial park set just north
of Venice on the mainland, called Marghera.
I sometimes work in the laboratory there in
the rather tube shaped tower. It's situated
between an oil refinery and a ship building
yard. So, when you leave the lab at night,
one is confronted with Tunis that are set
alight with toxic gases and the impression
of buildings that are moving as these ocean
liners are being assembled and constructed
on moving frameworks; it's very, very surreal.
So then, is it any wonder that environmentalists
are protesting wildly about the proposition
of the Moses Project. Here's some graffiti
on one of the walls on a house in Venice,
protesting about the Moses Gates, the 78 mechanical
gates that are set to be installed in the
lagoon of Venice and rather like the Danish
king, Kanut, are there to drive back the tides,
because the aqua alta, very much like the
shoreline environment, is not kind. As you
walk around the city, you start to see the
damage that the sea water, and particularly
the salt, ravages on the brickwork. You actually
start seeing the very material substances
within the city of Venice, the very fabric
of being digested away by the giant stomach
of the elements and the lagoon substances.
You can see effervescence here; quite liberally,
it's like the icing that's been dusted over
the walls. You can also see how very much
the marble and even the concrete that's been
stuffed in the holes in the brickwork is suffering
as the city fabric tries to retain integrity
at this very destructive interface. And you
see all kinds of architectural desperation
as you walk along the city. Here, you see
lion-like claw marks in the fabric of the
marble. And you also see odd bits of concrete
pasted in these holes that can take the fist,
the size of a fist, like someone's fired cannonballs
into the brickwork. And you'll see them also
filled with rubble and sand and rubbish and
even chewing gum. But there is hope. In the
oddest place, perhaps, in a public garden
to the east of Venice, is an oak tree. No
ordinary oak tree, this is a very special
oak tree. It's at the center of a very special
building, The Canadian Pavilion, which was
constructed by Enrico Peresutti. Now, the
oak tree is special because it stands right
in the middle of this building, which is wrapped
around it, according to the shell of a nautilus,
which is a mollusk, a squid-like mollusk that
has this banded structure. And under the natural
canopy is another canopy, an artificial canopy,
a cybernetic canopy, constructed by architect
Phillip Beasley with his collaborator, Rob
Gorbet. And the golden fruits that you see
within that canopy are fruits of my own enterprise,
some special chemical fruits, which I'll talk
to you about in a minute. But this is the
Hylozoic Ground Project. Essentially, it fills
the entire building and this cybernetic forest
literally responds to fluctuations within
the environment. The passage of air causes
the feather-like filters to flicker and shed
showers of dust into the atmosphere so you
can actually visualize the passage of the
air movement through the gallery space. Those
long tube-like structures in the center of
the gallery are actually swallowing tubes.
And what they do is they extend and contract
with hydraulics that are connected to the
cybernetic sensory systems, distributed throughout
this forest of senses and affecters. Also,
under investigation, of course, is the presence
of people and these swallowing tubes actually
are fitted with hairy tongues and you approach
them, the senses detect your presence and
they raise their hairy tongue-like structures
up to lick and tickle you. There were also
artificial crickets, which are those grape-like
structures which are just to one side, above
the light structure that you can see to the
left of the swallowing tubes. And they actually
scratch against each other and they make this
sound that's a bit like a cicada. So, in this
rich, synthetic ecology, are the fruits. Now,
this is one type of fruit. There are many
types of fruit and this one is a self-evolving
chemistry based on the properties of inorganic
substances, impregnated into a gel-like matrix.
And this is called the Liesegang reaction.
It's a precipitation diffusion reaction, which
is a load of jargon, but essentially what
it is; it's an embodied form of fractal reductions.
These chemistries gradually distribute themselves
through space and time and form a very elaborate
pattern structures that have been driven by
the forces of gravity and fueled by their
chemical interactions in which they're contextualized.
But this is the particular fruit that I want
you to have a look at. As you can see, there's
some opacities within its structure. And of
course this is all fueled by the, and speeded
up by the LEDs that are placed underneath,
under these fruits. And as we go closer, we
can actually see it's created of two layers
of oil. Within them are cell-like structures
that are highly colored. In fact, those colors
are there as indicators to show the public
that something is happening. And something's
happening at a very, very, very slow rate,
because actually, I've have to slow this all
down. Because believe it or not, and this
is one that's been shown by its reaction or
its response to the LED, cause believe it
or not, this is actually a very rapid process.
So, here is a film taken by my chemistry supervisor,
Martin Hanczyc, who actually invented this
technology. It's called a dynamic oil and
water droplet system. What you're going to
see is a qualitively new kind of technology
that's been called living technology. What's
new about it is that it's inherently complex.
It is not controlled by push button technology.
It does not respond according to the same
laws of operation that we've been accustomed
to over the 19th and 20th century, with mechanical,
digital technologies. Essentially, this simple
oil droplet in a medium of water, a little
bit of soap, and a lot of wriggling is a complete
technology. You can't take, you can't break
it up into components. It exists as a whole
from its essence; from the time of its birth.
What I find really amazing about this particular
sequence is that for me, this is not only
technologically a birthing process, but I
think also metaphorically it is heralding
a new age in computation. This is a form of
material computation, in which the material
itself is actually able to make decisions
and take actions depending on its environmental
context. So there are two ways of programming
this agent. One can either program it according
to its environment, so it behaves in a life-like
way. It can move around its environment, as
you can see here. It can sense it, so it can
follow a great inter-, operates through a
primitive form of kinictaxis. It undergoes
complex reactions, such as the shedding of
the skin, or even the production of a shell.
Not only that, it likes other protocells,
so it doesn't just operate as a lone agent,
but also in colonies. And in the video that
I've got installed here, you'll actually see
some of these populations' scaled-like phenomena,
which actually have not been described using
computational modeling. They are exhibiting,
in populations, phase-like phenomenon, so
that it's almost like quorum sensing in bacteria,
if anybody knows what that is. It's essentially,
bacteria operate according to their own little
set of rules and then when they're working
in a population, they all start talking to
each other. And when there's a quorum present,
whether it's six, whether it's eight, whether
its six thousand, suddenly there's a population
scale signal that is passed amongst these
primitive bacteria, actually some them very
sophisticated, too, and it causes a huge movement
of other bacteria towards this population.
We just found something interesting, normally
food, and then it creates this mass scale
migration towards the signaling center. So,
when these bacteria have reached the quorum,
they're able to make a new product that they
don't make when they're less than a quorum.
These protocells seem to be able to communicate
along those lines, even though they do not
possess any DNA. So, we can engineer them.
So we can either change their surroundings,
so they can follow different traces in the
environment, or we can actually load up the
body of the agents themselves with some chemical
information. And so, this is the final species
of fruit that I've created. And this is one
that can take carbon dioxide out of solution,
which is dissolved both from the Venice water
in which this agent has been placed and also
in the respiratory gases it breathes out by
the gallery visitors. And what you're seeing
is copper carbonate being dissolved in a halo-like
structure around the protocell that's worked
its way down to the bottom of the pear-shaped
flask in which it's being housed. So, what
could this be used for in an architectural
context? Well, I showed you some of the buildings
along the canal sites in Venice. Well, what
I've been able to do is to actually program
oil droplets using this chemistry to actually
create shell-like structures, made of carbonate,
which is like limestone, that bridge the gaps
between brick rubble. So, this is brick rubble
that was collected from a walk around the
city, I've scooped it up, put it into a Petri
dish, took it back to the lab, and then create
a paint-like substance, a watery paint. So,
this material, unlike the architecture around
New York, which dumps all its water onto the
street, wasting valuable resources, is actually
conducive to watery environments. So, you
can actually start seeing that these blob-like
structures are starting to produce milky deposits
as they repair the gaps between the brickwork,
but not only that, they actually create a
shell around the brickwork itself, which is
fixing carbon dioxide and also producing a
protective layer that delays, perhaps, the
corrosive effects of the highly saline and
corrosive environment in which these buildings
are situated. And really, if you keep applying
this, this paint, then you build up a form
of carbon dioxide capture an accretion around
the wall substance itself. And so, literally,
with various paint applications, you can build
this artificial shell-like structure around
the masonry. Within the next ten years, certainly
maybe even within the next five, it is likely
that these agents will be able to reproduce.
Currently, I've seen it done on an ad hoc
basis, so essentially, what DNA seems to do
is to stack up the chances of cell division.
However, even without any DNA, these protocells
actually divide and they fuse. It's a random
process. So, one can wonder whether or not
this actually constitutes a form of synthetic
life, which is being created using a bottom
up approach. So, it makes us wonder what it
is that we're thinking about when we're thinking
about life-like processes. Technically though,
this is not a life and this remains a living
technology. Really, really interestingly,
there are no more than about three or four
chemicals being used in this particular substance
here. Its fat, water, a bit of surfactant,
which like a soap just to break down the very
high pressures form surface tension around
the oil droplet because of the reaction between
oil and water. Of course, oil has this schizophrenic
relationship with water; it loves it on one
hand and hates it on the other hand. And any
disturbance in populations of oil molecules,
in relationship to a water interface, causes
great amount of movement and this actually
accounts for these physical phenomena that
we see with these dynamic oil and water droplets.
So, what could we do with a system that's
able to accrete a little bit of carbon dioxide?
And same, this is not geoengineering scale;
literally this builds a crystalline layer
around it. And how could we use this in architectural,
or even a design device? Well, propositionally,
we've come up with an idea that may provide
a way that illustrates how living technology
is qualitively different to the industrial
and digital technologies that we currently
know. So, in contrast to the Moses Gates,
which propose to keep back the tide, what
we've decided was that the protocells could
actually be released into the lagoon and programmed
to move away from the light-filled canals,
where they'd make their way to the darkened
foundations of Venice, which, as you probably
know, are built upon woodpiles. On reaching
this low energy threshold, they can then produce
their carbonate and create these little synthetic
shells around the woodpiles and gradually,
they accrete and form a reef-like structure
underneath the city. And so, the city of Venice
is currently standing on soft delta soils
with stilettos. By creating a form of accretion
underneath the city, we're changing those
stilettos into platform boots. And therefore,
we're attenuating the gradual sinking of the
city of Venice into the soft delta soils.
Obviously, Venice's problems and its relationship
with the environment is complex and certainly
accretion and the spreading of the point load
of the city is not going to be enough to solve
all its problems. But in some ways, it does
demonstrate how these living technologies
might actually engage with the environment
and create outcomes in a qualitavely different
kind of way to the industrial and digital
technologies that we're used to. And this
is a future Venice scenario where the reef
has accreted underneath the city and, as you
can see by capillary action through evaporation,
it's starting to form this protective layer
around the city. And you can see under the
Rialto Bridge there that they're actually
rather beautiful stalactite structures, which
I'm sure tourists will be breaking off these
lovely souvenirs as they pass underneath them
in their gondolas. So, what else could these
kinds of technologies do in the built environment?
This is a drawing; a speculatively being able
to create carbon fixing surfaces on future
cities. We don't need to create new architectures.
We could actually use this as a new form of
retrofitting, where we can create embodied
energy, return the positive impact of architecture
or allow our architecture to impact positively
on environments, rather than negatively. We
could also use these surfaces to trap carbon
dioxide and use sunlight to create biofuels.
And we're actually working with the Cronin
Group at the University of Glasgow to do exactly
this. So, we're really, this gives rise to
the next generation of solar panels, which
don't produce electricity, but biofuels directly
from sunlight and atmospheric carbon dioxide.
What's also very neat about these technologies
is because they're based on the properties
of life, they're ubiquitous, which means that
every community, providing it can, providing
it has cooking ingredients of oil and water
and maybe some inorganic chemistry, could
actually engage in exploration of this technology.
And ideally, we're not quite there with the
recipe yet, but what we'd like to do is actually
use mobile phones in developing countries
and SMS the recipes so that people can actually
make these materials for themselves and experiment
on them because, as I've demonstrated, they're
very environmentally contextualized. So, for
example, a protocell system made of exactly
the same ingredients is going to perform very
differently in Norway to an equatorial country.
And it will also vary differently on levels
above the sea. And one of my ambitions is
to send some of this protocell technology
into space because I know that it's driven
by chemical and physical forces. And of course,
microgravity is going to change the performance
of these droplets. And I think this would
be very useful information for us when we're
actually trying to design these on a larger
scale. What we're currently developing is
a manufacturing platform for these protocells.
We're working with people with 3D printing
expertise to literally create a birthing platform
through which our little protocells are released
into a watery tank, into their uterine environment,
and then we'd use 2D ink jet technology to
actually then give them specific chemistries.
And that way, we're going to actually be able
to quantify and be much more specific about
exactly how much chemistry is required in
a particular droplet of a particular size
in order to create a particular kind of outcome.
At the moment, all these experiments are done
by hand. So, I'm just, I'm-- yeah. I'll just
wind up now. So, essentially, I think really
from the perspective of living technology,
I think it's really relevant today. I think
in the context of architectural and environmental
uncertainty, what that value is is that they
can actually respond to one predictability
as a real-time event, rather than relying
on models in order to anticipate future events
that may or may not take place. And, in other
words, it responds to immediate changes in
the environment just like life does itself.
Thank you.
[applause]
Has anyone got any questions?
>>presenter: No.
>>Armstrong: I was-- there was a question,
there.
>>Male member #1: I heard you using words
like "rapid process is random."
>>Armstrong: Mm-hmm.
>>member #1: I was wondering what's the predictability
of they have hands, not feet? Cause it sounds,
I was wondering, would there be like a maintenance
issue or fallback boost that would be taken
into account once it gets going, what's the
[inaudible]?
>>Armstrong: I think it's a really good question
about control of the technology. Living systems,
I think, and the control of living systems,
I think is something that we're already familiar
with. And the way I describe this is its really
like cooking, ok? You, my grandmother used
to make cakes, ok? If she had some eggs and
some butter and some sugar and some flour,
she was gonna make a cake. Now, whether she
put chocolate in there or rum and raisins
or whipped it up with her great, big forearms
that she could strangle geese with, each time
she make a cake, it was cake, but it had different
flavors. And it depended how hot the oven
was, whether there was a change in the atmospheric
pressure, all these complex factors came into
play when she was actually making cake. They
were always delicious and essentially, through
her art and her practice and her expertise
and her familiarity with working with materials,
she actually understood, intuitively, the
parameters. Now, this particular technology
is actually much less complex than making
a cake. So, my point is that the way that
we engage with it is based on the principles
of complexity, but that doesn't mean that
it's unknowable. What we can do is we have
a good idea by creating these systems through
which we're going to evaluate them much more
specifically; we create conditions in which
the probability of a particular outcome is
likely. We can never say 100% certain, but
that doesn't mean that the technology itself
is out of control. Also, these are very dependent
on resources in their environment, so when
they run out of food, they just stop; they
go to sleep. One of the nice things about
the solar panels is that unlike green roofs,
say for example, which actually respire at
night, so when plants, they photosynthesize,
great, they fix carbon dioxide, but when the
lights go down, they're eating the same stuff
as we are and they're actually creating carbon
dioxide. So, a solar panel in the dark is
actually just gonna go to sleep and wait till
the sun rays come up again. It won't be using
any of the oils that it's been making during
the day when it wakes up again. So, I think,
I think that the techniques of control are
much more like agrarian practices. Cooking,
this kind of stra-, dealing with animals,
herding cats, that kind of thing. Obviously,
some-some chemical relationships are gonna
be more awkward and tricky to get working
then others, but I think the risk is actually
the precarity of actually working, not in
the fact that it's actually gonna go mad and
take over the world and turn it into grey
goo. But obviously, nothing is 100% certain
within a system like this, however, this is
something that we know and I think that, obviously,
one would do lots of field tests before doing
a Venice-scale project. But I don't think
this is something that we've never come across
before and therefore, I feel fairly confident
that my grandmother's recipe never turned
a cake into a sausage roll and that this kind
of approach would never really create a degree
of surprise that was totally unmanageable.
And what's quite interesting in parts of the
film that's on display is that there's a population-scale
event. Just watch for this, but it's about
two-thirds of the way through the film. What
you get is a home team of protocells that
are just building these long, stringy-like
structures. There are probably about ten of
them and they're all just minding their own
business, having a chat amongst each other,
wa-, you can see this little chemical bridges
forming between them and they're just gradually
creating these long tails. And over to the,
on the film its over to the right of the film,
you get a few waiting protocells wondering
what's going on, but they're very social.
Just have a look there, but, and I'm personifying,
and I know this anthropomorphizing and I know
it's all wrong scientifically, but this is
the best way to describe it. So, home team,
away team, away team comes to check out home
team, there's some kind of scuffle. What's
going on? All of a sudden, they all part and
they shed these long plume-like structures
after them. I have no idea why or how that
happens. I know that it is based on principles
of physics and chemistry. I know that there's
some form of exchange between them because
there was no information within these agents
to start with to actually, specifically ask
them to do that. So, I think with complex
technologies, we will actually get very interesting
phase changes that are extraordinary phenomena,
but not necessarily means that it's out of
control. I think it's more to do with the
capacity for surprise, but surprise within
a very predictable solution space. The lady
over there had a question.
>>Femalemember #2: I have one question that's
related to his, it's practically the same,
but now that you've elaborated systematically
[inaudible ]. One of the things that strikes
me as you mentioned [inaudible] technology
might develop here.
>>Armstrong: Oh. That will never have DNA?
No, that they'll be able to reproduce themselves.
Which is, yeah, which is, which is different.
In other words, it won't, they won't have
agents that are vectors to exchange with biological
systems.
>>member #2: For me, that's the reason that
I [inaudible]
>>Armstrong: Well, what's quite interesting
about them, though, is that they are very
alien. They, despite possessing an organic
body, they are actually quite alien to biological
systems. So, they are an alternative form
of biology. Lee Cronin describes it as an
artificial biology as opposed to a synthetic
biology, which is the modification of a known
biological system. So, they work in a qualitively
different way. Yes, I think they will have
medical implications. So, for example, currently
one of the biggest killers today is heart
disease and arterial disease. What's really
neat about protocells is that they're little
slow-release capsules and if we put in them
an agent that can digest cholesterol, which
we can't remove through mechanical means,
which is the way that we scrape out arteries
at the moment, we can actually introduce these
agents into the heart, very specifically,
through radiographic control guided mechanisms,
so you can cardiac cath to the point of the
blockage or if you see a throwing up of the
artery. And they'll release these agents and
they will literally digest away the chewing
gum on the inside of your heart vessels, even
before you've had a heart attack. See, cause
we can digest out clots using streptokinase,
which is great. We can do that chemically.
But if you've actually got coronary artery
disease, then you literally have to create
a bypass or a mechanical, mechanical thing
through it and that's risk of destroying your
arteries. So, it, so essentially, we will
use them inside the body, but in alien areas,
where biological systems have not been able
to create cure, so can you image no more heart
disease cause we're putting arterial deposits
into our bodies around about the age of 21.
So, you, it, we could manage to engineer these
so we can actually also whistle would call
them back. That would be the other thing.
Also means that people with kidney and liver
damage, we currently have a lot of problems
with treatments because they can't metabolize
or move drugs introduced into their bodies
through their urine systems, they can also
benefit from these kinds of things.
>>Female presenter: Ok, sorry to interrupt,
but we have to move to our second speaker.
We'll take the rest of the questions at the
end. So this, our second speaker--
[mic drops]
our second speaker tonight is Mitchell Joachim.
He's a leader in ecological design and urbanism.
He's a co-founder of Terreform ONE and Terrefuge
and he's an associate professor at the NYU.
And one bit of trivia I really liked is that
he has been chosen by Wired magazine in 2008
to be as one of the 15 people the next president
should listen to. So, let's listen.
[Mitchell and man speaking]
>>Mitchell: I run an organization in Brooklyn,
New York, called Terreform ONE. My co-founder,
Maria Aiolova, is here and I see some of our
students and some friends. So, you may be
familiar with the work, so this is going to,
I guess, be a description to those who haven't
seen it before and maybe slightly skeptical
of the work we do. And I'm certainly looking
forward to the part where Rachel and I can
have a conversation here, together with many
other minds because we've talked about what
it is that we do and the alliance that we
have and the kind of commonalities that we've
been working towards. And it seems to be very
extremely interesting, very exciting, but
a new field and we're not sure, exactly, what
that is just yet so maybe some of you can
chime in and let us know. So, the work at
Terreform ONE falls under these three metathemes,
which is the idea of the city, ecology and
mobility, which leads to a new theory of design,
which is ecotransology. Which is come from
a long history, standing on the shoulders
of giants, previously, Buckminster Fuller
would be one of them, about looking holistically
at the design of a city, doing everything
we can, from the doorknob to the democracy,
all right? The designer thinks about all aspects
of the city. So, it's not limited to scale.
It's not limited to some kind of silo of design,
but thinking about design from all aspects
and fighting this thesis, or this current
crisis, of the climate change. So, here is
a drawing by one of my favorite artists; a
curmudgeonly guy named R. Crumb, who's thinking
about the environment, in this case, in one
particular drawing. And it sums it up quite
elegantly, I think. The first part about the
environmental debate, here, I've listed as
zero, is the idea that the world will end,
all right? There's some feat of acid in the
ocean or acids in the sky or temperature changing,
etc., we're not gonna make it. And we usually
have some sort of an association of time,
which is we've got about 20 years to fix the
problem or we all die. And, I think this has
been a big message in the sustainable movement.
And I'm not a supporter of the message, whatsoever.
I think the first thing you do if you tell
average Americans which, I'm sure no one in
this room would be considered an average American,
and I don't think any American would consider
themselves average, thus the problem.
[laughter]
But we start telling that we're gonna die
because of the energy we consume. The first
thing they're gonna do is leave the lights
on, use the air conditioner all day long just
for their cat and buy the biggest possible
cars so they can speed up and down to live
life to its fullest before they die. Cause
they don't want to be like those other folks
who are very responsible. So, that's, I think
a big part of the American mindset and its
prompted by this theory of eschatology; the
apocalypse. So, I don't go there. The technological
fix and the ecotopic is something that we
do find our work falling in. It's somewhat
of a merger between those two metathemes;
technological fix being through some silver
bullet, some act of geoengineering, right?
We will solve our problems. John F. Kennedy
said it best, "If man created problems, man
can solve problems." So, this is the kind
of, the science will save us idea, and with
policy backing it up, of course. And the ecotopic
is this return to the ways and traditions
of nature; a kind of vernacular. Learn from
nature and we can dwell again on the Earth
peaceably. So, I think that's great, but I
think we can't ignore 100 to 150 years of
industrial progress and technology. So, the
work that we do, like I said, incorporates
everything about the city, and it's been done
before. So, here's a drawing. It's over 102
years old. It's King's Dream of New York by
Harry Pettit and this is where a designer
has holistically reconsidered the city. And
this is a proposition about the future of
New York and here, you can see dirigibles
connecting into skyscraper ports, or docks,
on the terminus of skyscrapers, moving in
to circulatory cores bridged clusters of skyscrapers
and then below, you can see a cannonaded system
of mobility where pedestrians are on arcaded
walkways, horses and buggies, fast moving
transportation, slow moving transportation
are all separated; designed holistically by
one designer. We do this, I guess professionally
as a non-profit at Terreform. Here is us on
the cover of Popular Science last month. This
was a big deal for us; we were very happy.
We're not sure what semiotic pulse this is
sent out. If you read it on the blogsphere,
there's all sorts of angry folks saying that
this can't possibly be the green city of the
future. And they start saying X, Y and Z and
there's consistent argument. And through one
image, it's very hard to communicate what
the future might be like. I think what's important
here is for them to talk about many of these
different technologies and ideas that are
involved in this drawing and I'll unpack them
slowly, but the most important thing about
this image is that we want the future, if
it happens, we want the future to be fabulous
and I think that's what we're trying to get
at. At some point, it's gotta, not only an
aesthetic driver, but it's gotta be a place
that we've always wanted to get to. And, of
course, that's a collective mind, a collective
mindset. So, we do some real research. We
do some real numbers, we do the back of the
envelope equations, we make a lot of mistakes,
we screw up a lot of experiments. I will show
you none of those mistakes here, but I'll
show you the end results of some of that research.
Here is a drawing looking at the entire history
of, for instance, mobility in the city of
New York, and how that relates to ecology
and energy. So, you can see somewhere on this
chart, and I didn't bring a laser pointer,
so I guess we can use this one here, but you
can see somewhere at the end of the chart,
they were looking at vehicles that are networked,
vehicles that are human powered, soft vehicles,
vehicles that talk to one another, and stacking
vehicle systems, all right? So, at MIT, where
I did my doctoral research, we were charged
with designing a car of the future. Thought
that was, well, a crappy idea because the
future eventually happen and they'll look
at our car ten years from now and it'll be
slightly anachronistic or laughable. So, we
wanted to design technologies. There were
a lexicon of ideas that would fit into every
vehicle everywhere. So, here is an example
of a wheel. The wheel is the car. You add
three of them together, and you get that--
a three-wheeled vehicle. We have drive train
suspension, motoring, and a modicum of intelligence
in that particular wheel. Here's one of many
iterations that we performed, looking at taking
those wheels and applying it to various kinds
of structural systems, canopy systems and
network systems. So, here we have what we
call, something called the city car. It is
a stackable car, it is a shared ownership
model so you don't own it; you buy into it
like the utility or zip car. The frame articulates,
or stands up, reducing its footprint by 33
percent. The next car comes in and it interlocks
with that vehicle, all right? And you can
stack about 330 of these on a New York City
block, as opposed to 34 SUVs. It's a facebook
on wheels, it's a drive by wire technology,
there's no mechanical linkages. You can take
the middle car if you so desire it because
the stack can part in the center if you need
it. And it doesn't have any information, like
the speed that you're going in. It just likes
to find out where your friends are, you tell
it and that's where you wanna go and off it
goes. And it solves what we call the last
five kilometer problem. Here's rethinking
the skin of these vehicles, making them soft
and sending out a message, something about
maybe if you're in Boston, the best thing
you can do is have a car that says, "The Yankees
rock," and I'm sure that would certainly bring
a lot of friends on the street, but you could
give a social-like posture to your vehicle.
And a kind of city of these soft-like cars
moving around. And we have over, or I did
at least over 40-something variations. Here,
in those soft shells with air quilt technology,
you can have an aperture that traces the drivers
viewpoint, creating a kind of hole, or the
entire car could be naked and you can have
a visor that tracks the sun, in this case.
Or here, you can add just a simple armature
to these wheels and the car can go vertically,
or spin on a dime. So, now we're designing
cars to fit cities, not the 20th century designed
around the car, but forms of mobility to fit
specific context. In this case, the city.
And it can enter the z-axis and I'll show
that. And that they'd be cluster of these
smart, soft, intelligent cars. Today, a vehicle
is a shiny, precious metal box; don't touch
me, don't look at me when I'm driving in them,
certainly don't get too close cause I'll get
scared. It's the opposite form of mobility.
This is called gentle congestion. The idea
is it's ok to rub up against the person next
to you, say "Chow," and continue on your way,
all right? And here's how you phase them in
the city so the red vehicles are the hard
Hummers and the blue are eventually these
series of translating soft cars, that are
intelligent, that move in a flock and communicate
to one another, so when they find one of these
Hummers on the road, they cluster around it
and move it off to the side while these intelligent
cars take over the road.
[laughter]
Here's Omni Bub. This one is using soy-based
plastics as its solution for its canopy. And
here they are, separating passenger conditions
from freight conditions; going vertically
up a building. Here you can see in the cluster,
connecting to the skyscraper cores and connecting
office space to office space. We also wanted
to make a car that you could eat; an edible
car. And we thought, "Wow. Great idea. Finally
something original." No, much to my chagrin,
the research that I found out, Henry Ford
did it. He produced a vehicle that was made
out of soy-based plastics, grown in an experimental
lab. He wanted to merge America's grand agricultural
economy with its automobile economy. And here
he is, testing it out with an axe. Car grown
from soy. And it bounces off the vehicle,
right? The body of the car, for the press,
does not leave any kind of a scratch because
the coloration is impregnated in the material.
It's pretty fantastic. So, we use all different
types of starch foams, air bladders, air quilts,
to make the car soft as possible. In fact,
the first principle of our designs, which
is something that you can do when you're in
academia, not necessarily working for a big,
corporate place. Oh, I think there are many
corporate places that have different attitudes.
[laughter]
Here, the idea would be, our first principle,
our first signal of human intention, would
be that no one will ever die in a car accident
again. So, let's make cars go at a certain
speed, right? Thirty miles or less. Let's
make every part of these materials that go
into them something that considers others
on the road. This is a vehicle. It's basically
a big Nerf ball. That's not actually my term,
but Colbert came up with that and I'm gonna
use it and I think its right, these are Nerf
cars. So, if they hit your sister, they tickle
her; they don't kill her and that's the point.
And they have radically new systems applied
to them to think about breaking, to think
about proximity, to think about a grammar
of moving in flux, all right? So, here is
what we call the contact patch that's just
below where the wheel touches the road and
we have the, in this case, that creates friction
to stop a car. This case, this vehicle, the
entire belly of the car hits the road, increasing
that friction by ten thousand fold; so, a
big soft car just like a beach ball would
fall on top of you if it doesn't completely
stop. They go flaccid, you, because they're
mostly made out of pneumatics, or air-based
systems, you can stack them like pancakes,
pull them out like a surfboard, with an attendant
you've got your car. Here, this vehicle, I
was thinking of, well, we had a new sponsor.
In this case, Reebok. They want to get into
making the bodies for these very smart, omnidirectional
intelligent wheels, so we present the shoe
car and we thought they would be pretty fantastic.
Here, it's got a, what's most noticeable is
the zipper to get in and out of the vehicle.
[chuckles]
Thank you, Europe, here is a smart car. We
don't use them enough here. Eighty-six inches
in length. Pretty fantastic, can park perpendicular
to the curb. Here's another version of our
car. Same, same footprint, but remember, these
two wheels articulate and the frame stands
up, so we're smaller than the smart car by
33 percent. You can park perpendicular to
the curb and get off direct onto the sidewalk.
It considers the young and the old. There's
a lip to get in and out of the vehicle. We
considered ingress and egress, a canopy to
protect you from the elements and then fitting
them into the street and this no longer becomes
a talk about cars. At this point, this is
when we start thinking, "It's not about vehicles.
In fact, vehicles are nowhere near as important
anymore. These are very big batteries on wheels."
And if you have a certain critical mass of
them, you can absorb peak demands and distribute
loads of electricity, or energy, in a new
kind of city grid. A city grid that's always
updatable and adaptable. So, it's no longer
the antiquated system that we have now, but
a new system that's alive and fully integrated
with something like mobility. So, this is
here showing that most of it would hopefully
be culled from alternative sources, or renewable
sources, eventually that would happen. And
thinking about not only the energy coming
from the vehicles being completely renewable,
but other energy sources that we carry ourselves.
Now, for moving around, these soft cars that
are powered ultimately by electricity, batteries,
people will always say, "Well, what about
human health and the environment?" Well, we
have other versions. In this case, it's the
New York City river gym. It is powered by
the human buttocks. As you work out, that
power is harnessed, trickles down to the drive
train, and you move on a loop between let's
say Brooklyn and Wall Street, from locker
room to locker room. So, there are ways to
use human mobility for specific methods of
transportation. And then here, another form.
And this was a fantasy of air-based transportation.
This was thinking about the Thanksgiving Day
parade, which you guys must know about here
in New York. As a kid, it was surely startling.
I was in love with Spiderman. Now, I see SpongeBob,
etc., but you see about 50 people, sometimes
40 trying to hold down these balloons as they
march endlessly through the streets and then
it stops after a couple of hours. And I'm
thinking, "Why stop it? Let's just keep it
going. All day long, every day, down 5th Avenue,
down 10th, whatever you wanna do. Let's harness
that and use it as a transportation system."
You hop on, you hop off, go five blocks, go
forty blocks in these gently tendrils with
soft, ski lift like chairs and maybe an attendant
to help those folks who can't get on it, but
constantly moving at about 13 miles an hour.
Another thing about these same air-based systems
where they can also help support cleaning
the atmosphere. And this is looking at docking
stations, etc., and this narrative goes on
for a long time. And then all of these combined
into something that we call soft mobs and
smart dots. It, not only are all these things
talking to one another and connected and radically
new, but we privileged the most important
thing about a city and movement, which is
the pedestrian, the alpha position of a foot,
it's the best interface for a city, and bicycling.
It's also a phenomenal invention; doesn't
need much more. So, we privileged that and
we also give the road a bit of intelligence
as well. In this case, the road would have
a RFID tag system. If it senses a little girl
who drops her ball in the street, the road
can renegotiate traffic around that little
girl and she can pick up her ball, but if
you know anything about kids, once they know
that they can do that, they'll disrupt traffic
all the time. So, none of these systems are
perfect, but we are certainly, folks, thinking
about them.
[chuckles]
And now the jet pack. The jet pack, and I
told this story and its absolutely true, I
sat in a room with a bunch of folks like yourself
and some other folks who are experts in urbanism,
and someone, someone said, "My kid brother
said, 'Look, you've studied urbanism your
entire life and city planning. I think that's
great, but what happens when someone invents
the jet pack? Right? Doesn't all that knowledge
and all the things you've done just simply
go away?'" And my colleague, who was on the
panel, dismissed that and said, "Hahahaha.
That's whatever, not gonna happen." And I
thought, "Well, of course it's going to happen.
At some level, sometime it will eventually
happen. Who's thinking about it and what are
the ramifications?" And certainly we can't
allow jet pack designers to design them. Why
not architects and urbanists and scientists
think about what that jet pack should be?
And, of course, we want it to be soft. We
want it to move in flocks and herds and be
fairly intelligent, and there are jet packs
that you can buy today. Jetpack International,
Martin Jetpacks, they're a hundred thousand
dollars, you can buy a jet pack, it runs on
hydrogen peroxide catalyzed by a metal. It
can go for about 20 minutes maximum travelling,
but you can get from Newark, New Jersey to
Wall Street in minutes, as opposed to almost
an hour in an SUV and you don't have to park.
And they move like this, like a paaa, they
float and another one can move and paaaa,
they can bounce into one another and paaaa,
and you land.
[laughter]
And you unzip yourself and out you go to work.
And we thought about let's think what kind
of a society or what kind of a form of mobility,
what was this form of mobility do to the city?
And thinking that way, we must need long range
systems, so here's a sky tub that would take
groups of them from let's say, Boston to New
York and then you attenuate; you break off
to get to your local destination. And then
thinking about what Obama meant by the smart
grid and what he could be doing that is the
100%, self-sufficient, radically green solution
when it comes to this smart grid fantasy that
we all have for the United States of America?
So, we start thinking about what's the problem
with the grid in the first place? Well, that's
what you see, I think, on your left, which
is sprawl. Sprawl deals with going into green
fields, spreading issues of energy, waste,
food, water, etc., and rethinking sprawl into
a linear urban model and how we could use
that linear urban model, retool essentially,
the suburbs and put them on our existing pieces
of infrastructure; our existing arteries of
mobility. Use them and fit them out with waste,
food, water, energy, data, etc., and this
would be the smart grid or radical smart grid
where populations are connected to our arteries
of mobility, all right? So, I don't care how
people move in this particular kind of fashion.
We are actually rebranding white trash, because
with the trailer is a phenomenal way to live,
especially if you look at the lifecycle analysis,
it's radically green. So, here you would see
a series of trailers or combines moving, or
any way you want to get your house moving
and here is geothermal wind, photovoltaic
areas for food, data, high-speed transportation,
and you move from city core to city core.
You're always within a 45 minute loop and
you get the suburbs moving and moving and
moving. And the idea here is actually not
novel, either. I had Margaret Crawford, head
of Theory at Harvard tell me at dinner that
she's actually seen this before. It's actually
been a serious proposal in 1917, the Soviets,
the disurbanists, decided that they wanted
to do the exact same thing. Their populations,
outside of the peri-urban condition, needed
to be constantly moving, constantly mobile.
The reason for that is they wanted to avoid
nuclear holocaust. So, they wanted to keep
those populations going. They didn't do it
for reasons of the environment. So, this has
been a proposition that's been around. To
pimp your house out like this with some kind
of wheels, cost about one-fourth the price
of your home. So, for about a 400 thousand
dollar home, another hundred thousand you
can get it moving in any kind of fashion and
that's showing the suburbs leaving, and we
built these just giant models that express
this form of movement. We call this project
Homeway: The Great Suburban Exodus, and here
we move from the linear suburb model to a
city core and you can see this kind of thing
happening here, again, with areas that are
meant to be fit out for density and intensity
and energy, food, etc., places to rest for
a few months. So, if you like Florida, you
hang out there. You get bored of Miami because
there's maybe not too many libraries and too
many bathing suits, you go to New York.
[laughter]
And here you are moving in these homes along
these streams. This would be an example of
a house party, so if you don't like your neighbor,
you can confront him for just a couple of
days, have a party then slowly drive away.
[laughter]
And then another project that's also has been
around. This was called the Fab Tree Hab.
This is also thinking radically about how
we can be completely green. This is looking
at a technology that's 2500 years old. It
is called pleaching, its grafting trees together.
Actually, woody plants because you don't have
to do it to tree scale. You can use vines
and other matter that grows quicker, and I'll
talk about that in a second. But essentially,
the trees are grafted whether it's the same
species or interspecies, into one contiguous,
vascular system. And this is our contribution
to this is we use computer geometry to make
scaffolding, weave the plants through it while
they're wet or while they're root taps, and
we gently guide them into a very specific
shape; a shape that's meant for dwelling.
Then they're in-filled with horsehair or cob
or something, or clay. And you make a kind
of home. We have been experimenting with this,
off and on, since 2002. Here's one version
on the roof in Brooklyn, looking at willows,
looking at issues of infestation from insects,
lack of solar income, capillary activity and
water, etc. And this would be a kind of fit-out
of one of the entire homes. It doesn't have
to be in a shape; it can be in any shape.
But this is a home that is the landscape.
It is fitted into the metabolism of its local
environment. It is a contributor to our atmosphere,
not something that takes away, not a compromise,
not a zero model, right? I'm not big on zero
impact things. It's kind of like Switzerland.
It doesn't do good or bad, it's just kind
of there.
[laughter]
Any Swiss people here? Yeah, all right, well.
This is not a neutral model. This is a positive
ecological model. It is responsible and accountable
for 100 years of industrial pollution and
it scrubs and cleans the air. That's the point.
You can pre-grow a village of these homes,
within seven to ten years. And I think that's
fantastic. And that's been one of the criticisms.
You actually, there's plants that are available
now, and trees. A company called ArborGen
in Wisconsin who can give us trees that will
grow 80 feet in a year. This is interesting,
but I'm not sure in the, about doing that,
especially in practice. We use the precautionary
principle in science. We don't wanna release
genetically modified trees into the environment;
we think we can do it with a piece of nature
as it is, as it works just fine. Guide it
and shape it and that's it. It takes seven
to ten years. And people complain, "I don't
wanna wait that long for a house." Well, I'd
say, "You wait 12 years for a bottle of scotch?
I think we can wait seven years for a home."
[laughter]
So, here's one of our, well, enough of the
vegetable home. We have been working in, in
a completely different home, which is an experiment
in a series of questions. And this is where
we, just like Rachel, have been taking on
biology as a much deeper topic in architecture
and design. This is actually not a photo of
the entire lab; the lab is tripled in size
now. There are seven biologists, Do-It-Yourself
Biology New York, GenSpace and Dr. Alva Medvedic,
who is over here leading this, we decided
to experiment with cells, molecular cell biology,
and work on creating new geometries for industrial
design uses. In this case, you can imagine
making leather belts or leather shoes from
cells that you print, where no creature is
harmed, no sentient being is hurt. It's a
victimless industrial design procedure. One
way to do it is modified ink jet printers,
printing a geometry from the computer clumps
of cells, and form shapes that you fold up
around a polyglycaic acid scaffolds, here,
Princeton's forming a bladder. This has been
around in regenerative medicine since 2001.
This is essentially for folks who've got cancer
and you replace their bladder with this particular
element. You can replace esophagi, cartilage
in knees, etc. You can also use keratin cells,
like fingernails and all different types of
materials to make other things. When we heard
we could control geometry and make shapes,
we went for it. We started a proposition of
doing it at the house scale. Performing acts
of synthetic biology at this scale has not
been done before, and we were looking at the
limitations of our equipment producing a grammar
for dealing with those limitations, and making
a home that would be grown out of meat cells,
or in this case, pig cells.
[laughter]
So, this is what you'd see; a typical stud
wall in any home in America and then our meat
house proposition, which is a very different
kind of tectonic solution. Here, looking at
fatty cells as insulation, cilia for wind
loads and we, I think, we've known this before,
but sphincter muscles for doors and windows.
Felt that seems to be the best possible solution
if we're gonna make a house of meat. And yes,
it would cleaned and we'd bleach the door,
I guess, before you get in.
[laughter]
And it's, this is one possible shape. It could
be any shape, making it a Victorian or a English
Tudor would just be wrong, so this thing that
seemed to make a spectacle of the anus entryways
and windows; we're all for it. And this is
the version that we have for the lab. It is
essentially, if you think of the cost of doing
something like this from regenerative medicine,
you can't keep it alive, you're producing,
printing pig cells out of, into a specific
geometry and then you saturate them in nitrates
and sulfates and preservatives, cause you
can't keep it alive. It has no immunological
system, it has no skeletal system, it has
no kind of a blood vessels to keep it healthy.
As soon as it, that it's exposed to the atmosphere,
it dies. So, we wanted it to be constantly
preserved just like beef jerky and it's very
expensive to do something like that and we're
very happy with what we got. It's been alive
for, I guess, three were dead for about three
years; it hasn't rotted. It's like a Twinkie,
it's got a--
[laughter]
shelf-life forever. And we know about the
issues that it brings up. The point is experimentation.
The point is to find some questions and attack
them; look for more of those answers. So,
we had a big show in Prague and we put the
meat house in front of the cathedral so religion,
you could confront this monster. And then
finally a thing about cities and city scale.
This is something my daughter, is completely
in love with this robot, the most affable
robot on Earth. He's a nonstop nebacunezzar,
piling trash all day long, to these specific
shapes, throughout the same thing; automate
a puzzle-fitting system for waste. Instead
of cells, it would be waste bay systems. So,
we looked at the city of New York. Again,
more research. Here, going from 1613 when
Indians were around, zero tons of trash per
day, at least that we know of, to today, 36
thousand tons of trash a day produced in the
city of New York. If I was an alien race peering
down at Earth with some kind of telescope,
I would think that the city, especially New
York, was invented to make waste. That's what
we do. So, we're looking at this as a kind
of a resource; waste as a resource, waste
as a nutrient, to be automated and controlled
to produce new architecture, new civic spaces,
new ways of thinking about the city. Here's
a chart of the research. You can't possibly
unpack all of that very quickly, but we've
looked at the policies that have been in place
from ocean dumping to McDonald's stopping
hamburger boxes, or Styrofoam clamshells.
And looking at off the shelf technologies,
they are basically just like Wall-E. These
are bale makers, or crushers that can take
all sorts of things from plastics to cardboard,
and make them into dumb boxes. We're thinking
modify their jaws ever so slightly, make them
into puzzle fitting shapes that can produce
archways or corbelled domes new kinds of architecture;
puzzle fitting bricks. Kind of a Legos made
from waste. And here's a drawing that, I think,
tries to explain, or show visually, to the
everyday American the amount of waste we produce
in an hour in the city of New York. It's more
than the Statue of Liberty. This is the amount
of compacted waste in one hour in the city
of New York. I did a model for the MoMA, also,
I, showing the same thing. And thinking about
separating the uses of that waste from here,
plastics or clear based waste, can be used
for fenestration. Organic matter can be used
as temporary scaffolds to hold up the inorganic
matter and then it rots away. And here we'll
be mining it with all sorts of processes and
then looking at doing an entire skyscraper
made out of compacted waste. So, here's a
53-story tower that we call Oneday Tower,
because it takes 24 hours of waste in the
city of New York, it makes a 53-story skyscraper.
So, here we're showing the waste being delivered,
constantly produced. We've got all sorts of
interesting things; vertical gardens, jet
pack ports, etc. And this is our kind of rapid
refuse tower. And then this becomes a theory
of a new kind of city. A city that moves from
the age of industrialization to the age of
consumerism to an age of recovery, where we
mine our waste and use it to retrofit our
buildings and then finally, a city where there
is no waste. Waste has gone away, right? Gertrude
Stein said it best, "A way has gone away."
If you wanna make a city where nothing is
tossed out, everything is constantly created
and upcycled. So, you go to a city of industrialization
to a city of creation to creation to creation.
And focusing that specifically on one area
in New York, the Lower East Side, or Lower
East Side-a, and we're looking at many other
aspects besides waste, but all of these things
confronting one another: waste, food, water,
energy. All thinking about the city in a finer
kind of detail. We did this for The History
Channel. The base principle here, for this
kind of a city, is over a period of time,
a hundred years, we'll reverse the figure
ground and do something that we haven't actually
done, which is make green space. But not dumb
and naive green space, productive green space.
Green space that deals with our energy needs,
deals with the things that we need to survive.
Make a city that's 100% self-sufficient within
its political boundaries; a city with no inputs
or outputs, a city that's entirely self-contained.
Here we are rethinking Kentucky Fried Chicken
in some type of vertical farm/space to sell
food. And then the entire figure ground of
the city of Manhattan switched over. Where
buildings used to be, replace them with productive
green spaces and where the streets are, we'd
place them in with the buildings. Here, you
can see some of those details. And here's
a view of Central Park, in the future, dealing
with food and changing Central Park so that
we'd be able to feed the nine million people
that we cap the population in. And then looking
at the energy use of this particular city
and we'd move this over to Brooklyn and this
is, and if you've probably heard this argument
before, if New York City was the 51st state
in the United States, it would be the greenest,
most sustainable state in the entire continent.
Period. All right? This is the amount of megawatts
per hour that the average person uses in the
United States. It's 63 and in New York City
today, it's at 42, which is pretty great.
It's mostly due to the lack of petroleum and
moving around in cars and shared stack effects
in energy. If you heat your apartment, the
guy above you, Vinny, gets some of that heat
and when he heats an apartment, etc. If you're
in the suburbs and you heat your building,
it goes out into the atmosphere. So, we had
looked at the energy systems, the food systems,
the waste systems and the mobility systems
that make up the city of Brooklyn and I guess
this is our last project these last few images
that I'll show you, I'll just describe what
Brooklyn would look like in a future that
is 100 percent self-sufficient, where there
are no inputs and outputs and it's a radically
green city inside there. So, you can see here
there are some statistics about making it
run completely on solar, for instance. That
would mean all of Staten Island and 18% of
the land area of Brooklyn would be all solar
cells, running at 23% efficiency, we'd meet
the megawatt usages that we would need. All
right? But that would absurd just to use solar
cells in that faction. There are three thousand
acres of unshaded roof space in the city of
New York where we could fit those solar panel
to. And we don't just have to use sun. We
certainly can use wind, geothermal, water-based
energies to rethink of our city as a city
that runs on pure renewables. So, we're doing
this to get, basically, I love Blumberg's
plan for a green New York. I think that it
has some things that are impossible to argue
with in that plan, like everyone will be ten
minutes from a park in about 50 years from
now in the city of New York. And I think that's,
that's great, but what does it mean to be
radically green in the city of New York? What
does it look like? What are the numbers? And
how do you fit it out and it must be kind
of fabulous. So, I'm gonna end on this particular
view of us urbaneering Brooklyn to be completely
green and I think it's, I'll take some questions.
So, thanks. Thanks very much. Thank you.
[applause]
[pause]
>>presenter: Questions? Questions?
>>Male member #3: I just had a little question.
Just, I don't want to seem to be picking,
but just on that slide, just a couple back,
you said something about 22 megawatts per
person per day?
>>Mitchell: Per hour.
>>member #3: Per hour?
>>Mitchell: Yeah.
>>member #3: When is that actually being used
for? That's a lot of energy.
>>Mitchell: Yeah. That's taking into account
everything. So, that's commercial uses, that's
industrial uses, that's, that's taking the
population of the entire United States and
the amount of energy that we use and cutting
it up, exactly like that. And then capping
the population of New York, knowing the entire
energy the city of New York uses, cutting
it up per population.
>>member #3: So there's probably some folks--
[speaking in background]
It's like 300 million people.
>>Mitchell: Yeah.
>>member #3: And then the population of the
United States uses about thousands of terawatts?
>>member #4: We don't have that energy or
capacity.
>>member #3: That kind of energy, it doesn't
fit. There's something wrong.
>>member #4: [inaudible]
>>Mitchell: Oh well. I'm pretty sure that's
the exact number. I don't, I can't--
>>member #3: It seems to be off by like, multiples
of magnitude.
>>member #4: Its a few orders of magnitude--
>>member #3: How could you possibly get the
energy out from the sun?
>>Mitchell: Yeah, it's true. Maybe, maybe
it is per day. I don't know. I think that
that's pretty much the numbers that we got,
but now that I'm doing it, I mean, I'll refer
back to the slide, but let's look here.
>>member #3: Maybe that one's like a future
prediction.
>>member #4: An order of magnitude--
>>Mitchell: No, no. It's, it's--
>>member #3: [inaudible]
>>Mitchell: we just did it this summer, so
it looks a little bright and I don't wanna
screw it up. Yeah, oh, per year. Sorry, ok,
that's my fault.
>>member #3: Ahh.
>>member #4: What does it say?
>>presenter, member #3, Rachel: Per year.
>>member #4: Oh, ok.
>>member #3: That's more like it.
[laughter]
>>Mitchell: Brain fart. It happens.
>>member #3: That's ok.
>>member #3 and #4: That's what we get.
>>Mitchell: Good. Good question. Thank you.
[laughter]
>>member #4: Didn't work, you're just taking
it.
>>member #5: Is it because of the sky, or
[inaudible] that's actually implementing [inaudible]
permission--
>>Mitchell: Umm. Well, so, we certainly do
advise companies and help them on problems
that they, if they've had difficult, difficulties
creating solutions for. We take on any particular
subject. Between the group of us, it doesn't
really seem we have any limits per se. We
would take on, for instance, FedEx would have
a problem with parking tickets in the city
of New York and they needed to deal with issues
with mobility, issues with urbanism, issues
with technology and they certainly have a
great staff working for them, but they needed
somebody to figure out some answers on their
own. So, we looked at their problem, parking
tickets in the city of New York, and thought,
"Well, why not add these FedEx trucks, hire
one or two more people on the truck and never
stop. Constantly keep them moving and never
make a left turn in the city of New York."
So, not only does it get more employees, but
it solves the problem in the simplest possible
way. And we don't always look for radically,
out of the box, kind of solutions. We've been
asked before from the Obama Administration,
"What can we do right now, right now, that's
an off the shelf technology, to deal with
the energy suck in the United States?" And
it's simple. Change the light bulbs. Go out
and change the light bulbs. You can save 45%
of the energy usage. That doesn't mean people
do it. It's been known for years. There's
now policy about changing those light bulbs
and I know there's some issues about mercury,
but they're not as bad as you think. The bottom
line is that why aren't American doing it?
Are they simply not excited about going out,
changing some light bulbs? That might be it.
There's probably a whole host of other issues,
but it's certainly available. We use ten thousand
lumens per square foot on a desk in an office.
There's no reason for something like that.
So, a lot of the solutions we look towards,
we actually go for the easy answer, maybe
the kind of hack answer if you wanna say it,
but those work. And some of the things that
we look at are about desire lines. Proppositions
or reification of the city, we'd like to see
in the near future that are based on technologies
that we find available today. I don't think,
more or less, anything that we've shown doesn't
exist in some fashion. I think it's the kind
of narrative that we find in science fiction
that we're actually in love with. Science
fiction used to be slightly pooh-poohed. I
think if you'd mentioned that before, people
would get psyched or upset, but if you look
at the history of science fiction, its contribution
to humanity is immense. You can go all the
way back to Jules Verne, right? Hundreds of
years ago, he was, he wrote a narrative, not
a promissory narrative, he didn't make any
promises, he just said, "Here's a narrative
about getting to the moon." And he got into
the entire culture of how that would happen.
And he imagined it would be a staged rocket
that would leave from Florida, that would
drop off elements, land on the moon, return
with a different capsule that would go through
the atmosphere and would land in the water.
And you can imagine a hundred years later,
the engineers at NASA, directed by Kennedy
to go to the moon. They said, "Well, what
are some ideas?" They probably read Jules
Verne and said, "Let's see if this works out."
Did some numbers and started being more and
more convinced that that's the way to do it.
I think that that's, it stays in our hearts
and our minds and our imagination. The more
popular it is, actually, the probably more
likely it is to find itself reaching fruition.
That's also in telecommunications. As a kid
watching Star Trek, I never believed I would
have a hand held computer that I can talk
to anyone in the world with. Well, actually,
I sort of did believe that. So I wasn't so
surprised--
[laughter]
when we got them. So, so, some of the technologies
that we show, like the cars, which are off
the shelf and readily available, it's a matter
of it being exciting and fabulous and leapfrogging
the previous technology. It's the first adopters
buy it, when they do, people see that its
cool, radical and different and the log jam
opens up and it just starts to flow and many
other people jump on board with these kinds
of things. I mean, Apple's a company that's
been very successful with that pattern. Do
you have a question, sir?
>>presenter: We have to exit the space by
7:30, so for people who wanna look at the
exhibit, you have seven minutes.
[laughter]
So, you can pick, either ask questions or
look at the exhibit, but we have to be out.
>>Female member #6: Can I ask my question?
>>Mitchell: Yeah.
>>member #6: I'm wondering what happens to
a sense of history? It seems like culturally,
we're attached to things and like, your proposal
you preserve it hopefully and it seems like
in your proposition, it's destruction and
constructor of everything and in a green way,
but like one is the destruction of the transformation
to the [inaudible] and what about the nostalgia
and the idea of memory and history that, culturally,
people have.
>>Mitchell: Right. What I didn't have time
to say is that we do preserve a history of
architectural typology in anything that we're
changing. Historic preservation is essential.
And we do keep a lot of buildings. For instance,
in the Lower East Side project, if they're
gonna be around in 300 years from now, their
structures are that robust, we keep them.
If it's something that was built in the 70s
and looks like it's gonna rot away tomorrow
and is also a major energy polluter, we'll
take it down. So, we've got to do a kind of
audit of what's gonna be worth preserving
and what's not gonna be worth preserving.
A sense of history, I mean, is actually super
important. I think Rachel has achieved that
in her work as well. I think that there's
no doubt that we have to keep it preserved
as long as possible. But, and that's something
that I have to communicate directly when I'm
talking about it. It's just so much I can
say at the moment.
>>member #7: I have a question for Rachel.
Do we have the mic anymore? You had mentioned
protocells [inaudible]. And I was wondering
if you could elaborate on that? Is it a matter
of just conditions and ingredients?
>>Rachel: So, unpublished work, but essentially
you can produce fusion and fission of protocells
with really, really simple ingredients. In
fact, what I haven't shown you is some of
the work going on with another group of synthetic
agents, which is based on inorganic chemistry,
so the team of the work, we've got the University
of Glasgow, the Cronin Group. I'm determined
to get a Nobel Prize for creating the first
inorganic chemistry as a life form and essentially,
there are these species that NASA designed
from this, a bottom up set using lots of ingredients
to create different outcomes. But essentially,
because we're planning them to build them
up you can pretty much control, within the
realms of how far you can control a complex
system that's very simple, whether or not
we can thread more of them. I mean, obviously,
the technologies are young. We can do it.
We can do it. At the moment, we're relying
on issues of printing, 3D printing, 2D printing
in order to be the birthing agents because
we'll want to specifically have them in time
and space. Once we start getting the manufacturing
platform that we can then get data off, we'll
have a lot more information about exactly
what we need to do to create them.
>>member #7: So then you can have a self-sustaining
colony?
>>Rachel: You'd could be providing the nutrients
there, but also you can get colonies that
do different things, but connected in different
ways so that metabolism and waste products
of one becomes the food for the next, which
might stimulate growth or repair in another
one, so at the moment a lot of synthetic biology
is following the principles of biology, or
biomimicry, is very strong there. So, other
groups working with these protocells are actually
trying to take receptors from existing biological
cells and stick it into the membranes of these,
well not the membranes but the [inaudible]
water droplet systems. So you will get biological
synthetic hybrids and I mean that these agents
actually, I think, take off where nanotechnology
didn't quite get it. In other words, it's
got a matrix, and one of the things that I
would need, so it's got the software to communicate
across distance between elements that are
part of the complex ecology. So, essentially,
the kinds of things that you want it to do
is to actually use the old system and put
nanostructures in there and see whether or
not actually you get dynamic dialogues going
on between engineered nanostructures.
>>member #7: Great. But then--
>>Rachel: Yes.
>>member #7: As somebody else put it, you
responded that, I think, that somebody brought
the idea that if things get out of hand, say
you brought up there's no DNA--
>>Rachel: Yeah, no genetics.
>>member #7: But nevertheless though, one
can see that theoretically could have a situation
where it gets out of hand because if, if the
environment changes and well, not only the
environment, protocells change then their
demands on the environment and their change
and your ability then to control them needs
to change in response to that. And everybody's
gotta keep up.
>>Mitchell: Test environment.
[Rachel laughs]
>>member #7: Unless I'm just not articulating
it right.
>>Rachel: No, I understand what you're saying--
>>member #7: Like you did say, this is proposed
to be a completely different form of life.
>>Rachel: Correct. And also it's wired to
be right at the origins, right at the origins
of life. So, a bit like early Earth, it's
probably going to be extinguished many, many,
many times before we actually get systems
that are integrated--
>>member #7: Take home.
>>Rachel: especially to yeah, to weather a
lot of environmental variation. Right now,
they've been incredibly unruly environments.
>>member #7: Or they could be just extremely
lucky.
>>Rachel: They could be extremely lucky. So,
I mean, engineered and I think the key principle
here is about design. So, finding the right
context for these to exist, actually is one
of the things that we try to do quite early
on with choosing the site of Venice has been
meaningful when you start articulating a possibility
before then kind of saying this is the technology,
it helps to produce an agent that's disembodied,
that's alien and has these life-like properties;
it's immediately a scary proposition. So,
really think of it as being a material proposition
that can be designed. At the moment, the next
scale is gonna be really small, it's incredibly
fragile. It's gonna need considerations to,
and lots of monitoring the development in
order to get to the next stage. But we'll
get there and I think it does raise a form
of questions about control, about what we
think life is and about our relationship and
responsibility to the environment. I see a
neo [inaubile] coming back as opposed to this
idea that the inhabitants of the earth are
quite separate from everything else. I think
that these technologies are actually start
to display our global collectivity, not just
between me, but also [inaudible].
>>presenter: We're out of time.
>>Mitchell: Thanks guys.
[applause]